you look i'm i'm born in brooklyn raises
staten island i've been around the block
watching
new york sports media have people for
breakfast lunch and dinner
and the one thing you don't want to do
is
certainly when you were a star athlete
in this town um
blow off the media when you're supposed
to speak to him and then you get fined
for it
and then um as kyrie irving has done
uh with the brooklyn that's an you know
it's kind of like
of interest right when say
um kevin durant's now healthy when say
steve nash is your coach
when say you put out a video when you
hook up with the nets that you grew up
in new jersey a big what drozen petrovic
fan or whatever he claimed to be at the
time
you know something like that you know he
he lived through the calipari years
though
basically he was bemoaning or whatever
he carried kids that video of him
crossing the brooklyn bridge
i mean it's look you and then you put a
little bit more chum in the waters
by going on instagram and quoting
malcolm x and
saying i do not talk to pawns my
attention is worth more
i pray we utilize the quote unquote find
money for the marginalized communities
in need especially
seeing where our world is presently i am
here for peace love and greatness so
stop distracting me and my team and
appreciate the art which is capitalized
by the way we move
differently over a different over here i
i i honestly don't know what any of that
means
and i saw uh you know i follow bomani
jones on twitter i enjoy his work
immensely and i figured let's get him on
here because he was
um quite uh taken by this as well
bomani jones here on the rich eisen show
from
the worldwide leader in sports as well
as his own podcast we'll talk about it
here as well
bomani how are you good to have you on
the program today good man how are you
i am fine um i'll give you the floor uh
what do you think is going on here with
kyrie irving
bomani i don't know i don't know like
that that's what the real world of the
story is like that's not the thing you
put on instagram today
i just wanted it to make sense that's
all like can this thing make sense you
don't want to talk to the media i
understand
that i do think that media members kind
of undersell
how annoying it must be to spend all
your time with people bombarding you
with questions because one thing about
media that's worth pointing out if
anything ever happens and we wind up
becoming the story we are
quick with the no comment until i talk
to my boss like we get it
we know why it is that they don't want
to talk to us but it's the don draper
line right that's what the money's for
that's the trade that everybody makes in
this game they kind of have to deal with
us
because it serves a greater good purpose
now all the way
somebody wants to ask kyrie irving if
lebron was a father figure to him and
that's like an absurdly really
stupid question and i'm sure they get
stupid questions
every day you shouldn't have to answer
that stupid question but like everyday
stupid questions this is just what
you're gonna get so i get why somebody
would be annoyed and bothered by the
idea of being forced to talk to us while
they are half dressed
all of that makes perfect sense and if
kyrie said i just really find you guys
to be annoying and i don't want to talk
to you
i think i could let that ride the
problem is he
always tries to like hypothesize and
take these things to these intellectual
places
that he doesn't like his he doesn't have
an all-access pass to this
intellectualism like there's a security
guard that stops him at a turn that's
like yo man
this is a little farther than you are
allowed to go but that does not stop him
and the next thing you know
he is quoting malcolm x to explain why
it is that he just doesn't want to talk
to us
no it doesn't work like that
i i i i agree uh and and in new york
that is just only going to serve to sure
why doesn't he want to talk
is it because lebron clapped back a
little bit
at his quote about how he's finally
playing with a player
who's you know going to take the shot at
the end or can make the shot at the end
meaning durant uh or um
harden wants to come there and houston's
saying we want kyrie and he did
and that might be true i mean is that
what's going on here
why doesn't he want to talk about it hey
i
i got to say this man i don't know if i
will ever be so gifted in my life as
being able to explain why it is that he
does any of these things that's actually
part of the problem
like if he could clearly explain or
would clearly explain because maybe he
can and simply hadn't
but if he would clearly explain where
he's coming from
on some of these things i think he'd
have a lot fewer problems on it but like
i look at the thing he put on instagram
and i really like know that
i do not understand what it is that you
were talking about now
it's possible that i don't understand
what he is talking about because
i am just not bright enough to get it
just throw it out there in the rebels
i don't know about that that could be
the case man you got to have some
some humility and self-awareness in this
world the reality is i think jesse
jackson was made this point
is that if you were talking to me and i
don't understand it it is probably your
fault like especially if you're in the
space of being a professional
communicator
he is in a space where if he wants us to
understand something
it is his responsibility to put it in
ways that we are
able to understand like we're not in a
place now where we're trying to twist
his words
we're legitimately in a place now saying
dog what are you talking about
uh so do we read into this
is that that it doesn't work out in in
in brooklyn uh you know what i mean like
that's that's the whole thing because
you know we all sit here on
shows and and have time to talk about
things like this and sometimes
overparse it and i always wonder
certainly in the nfl about
the uh blow-ups dust-ups that happen
when games aren't being played
and wonder how it does manifest itself
when games do start
to be played is this just a way to just
fill a friday before we're actually
tipping off or you think this is
one indication that once again kyrie is
going to be part of a situation
where a welcome is either worn out or uh
there might be one championship or none
at all what do you think
well i mean i mean let's be fair we all
walked into this with a measure of
skepticism because it is impossible to
walk into what the nets are putting
together here
without having some measure of
skepticism right but we all
i think that all of us who are observing
this are doing so
from that position so i do think that
it's fair to say that maybe
we can make things into something a
little bit more than they are because it
confirms the kinds of things that we
think are going to happen
the other thing though with kyrie is he
really gets on people's nerves
like in a very unique singular way right
like his
like normally when people are also like
space cadet type stuff we find it to be
kind of delightful
no one finds his space cadet to be fun
because it's so serious like he means
all of it so i think part of it
is kind of just a personal reaction um
to that people have
to kyrie irving and how this goes but i
do
think though they are running quite a
sociological experiment over there in
brooklyn
with this team in large part because i
don't know what kevin durant is going to
look like when he comes back but i'm
going to assume that kevin durant is
going to be the best player on the team
he has lived a life as a basketball
player already of being the best player
on the team but the dominant personality
on the team
is somebody else and that person is the
one who gets to dribble the ball up the
floor
he kind of got tired of that and went
somewhere else after a point
i'm surprised he signed up for it now
this is going to be a lot
like everything in brooklyn is going to
be a lot but that ain't our fault this
is like
objectively fascinating bomani jones
espn host commentator
and host of the right time with bomani
jones podcast right here on the rich
eisen show
would you have given paul george the max
226 if you were steve ballmer and had
all those bomber billions would you have
done that
yeah probably i mean you're not going to
get a whole lot of better players than
paul george like he's probably one of
the 10 or 12 best players in the nba and
that's the kind of money you pay
one of the 10 or 12 best players in the
nba it just so happens right now that he
is at our crosshairs for all these jokes
um for various reasons but like he's six
he's basically a six
nine two guard who can guard three or
four positions right
and can give you 35 on a given night
yeah that's about what that sort of
thing cost my question for them is
what like do we know that kawhi leonard
is gonna come back there like are we
positive
that that's something that he's gonna do
because they hitch their wagon to a
couple of guys that i don't know if like
even if they're really good are they
really like dependable in the way
that you need him to be so far the
answer to that is kind of ambiguous
so yeah i mean
i hope he does in the same way that i
hope giannis signs the super max because
they went ahead and mortgaged the future
for giroux holiday
right and so so you got you got teams
making these moves where you're hoping
that the
the uh next big most important step is
already decided not hoped for
or or trying to be a bouquet of roses
placed at their feet
uh from management saying we already
made this move so it's now time for you
to make your move
i sure hope so yeah well what i think is
going to be interesting is i'm wondering
if at some point
you're going to see a bit more of a
movement among players and free agency
decisions where you bet on the front
office
because i understand betting on location
and betting on what the roster is
at at a current point in time but the
smart bet is on the front office like
when
lebron left miami and went to cleveland
he seemed to realize pretty quickly
though oh man
i said on a really shaky front office
right so
miami's roster had gotten a little has
gotten to be something that maybe you
could win with okay but
pat riley's a dude that you think one
way or another is going to be able to
find a way to get it done like if he was
making lebron was making basketball
decisions
you bet on the front office i don't know
if the clippers have a front office that
you necessarily want to bet on and so if
you're kawhi
and none of us know what he does it
thanks because he ain't telling us a
damn thing like kyrie don't want to talk
to the media
kawhi let her talk to us it doesn't tell
us anything maybe you can learn to live
like him
because i don't i can't pretend to know
what he's going to want when his
contract is up
for marty what do you think pat riley's
first thought was
when i'm sure he didn't see it on
twitter on his phone somebody had to
tell him
i'll just throw that out there that
james harden put
miami on one of his wish list i want to
go to play for what do you think
went through riley's mind when he heard
that oh immediately trying to figure out
what way there
is for it to happen because pat riley
does not look at the world
in the same ways that we do like i see
the idea of trading assets away for
james harden
and as how are you going to build this
thing around james harden is the only
way to play ball with james harden with
james harden having the ball
all the time and things that stagnate
your offensive weather that's the guy
that you want around
pat riley is i am pat riley this is
like he's david ruffin right like i'm
david ruffin and these are the
temptations
that's how pat riley sees the heat this
is his team and so
yeah we'd bring james harden in here and
he would do what it is that we do
because not even with lebron james that
pat riley truly entertained the
possibility that he is going to bend
to what the player wants right they may
take your input
into account but he's the guy who's in
charge so if you tell him one of the
best five players in the nba
is available to be under his charge oh
he'll try to find a way
like if he wants it he'll find a way to
get this done because i don't think the
market is going to be nearly as robust
as james harden would have expected well
certainly not if if uh the rockets
are doing what they should do which is
okay
we've got two years of contractual
control remaining
um this player does not have a no trade
clause
however the nba gives you whatever trade
clause you want when a superstar usually
says i don't want to be here that said
you know they should look at
philadelphia and say well one of the
names better be
embiid or simmons i don't want to hear
about tobias harris or
well nets one of the names better be
kyrie i'm sure you're not going to be
talking about durant
but one of those names better pop up and
if you're
houston what the name is hero right or
or
autobio i mean that that that better be
the first name out of pat riley's mouth
otherwise enjoy playing with john wall
shouldn't that be there yeah
right i mean you can't give a play like
you think i've talked about this for a
while like some of the superstar trades
of back in the day like charles barkley
got traded for jeff hornacek tim perry
and andrew lang and after that season
andrew lang left philadelphia and went
back to phoenix
right you can't get away with making one
of those trades anymore not after you
get
all of that for paul george for example
not after the pelicans got all of that
for anthony davis
like you as a general manager can't go
face your boss and come back with a
terrible
package for james harden right and so i
think he thought that he could squeeze
himself into the one place he wanted to
go
just by stomping his feet and the
rockets were like nah we're not going to
do that
one thing to keep in mind with harden he
was represented by rob polinka
i think when rob felinka took his legacy
but the big thing is hard's mom
handles his affairs if i'm not mistaken
i know he does not i don't i do not
believe he has
like an official quote-unquote agent i
don't know
anything about his mother or anybody
that's around them i don't want a
question their savvy or anything like
that
right but i but there's a value in a
professional
you know and so if he is trying to run
his own strong arm campaign
without the aid of someone who does this
all the time
then this is going to be wonky ask
bomani jones the poll question before we
send him off
uh for the rest of his friday right here
on the rich eisen show go ahead
bomani it's the anniversary of the
lufthansa heist from goodfellas
what's the biggest heist in sports
gilbert arenas
albert hainsworth mike hampton bobby
bonilla
oh no oh why can i can i do my none of
the above please
what do you got frank mccourt bought the
dodgers with no
money and then sold them for a billion
dollars and still owns the parking lots
that's right he does that
we didn't think we just figured we
didn't think beyond just player
contracts i didn't think of that one but
that's what we have you want
that is a great title man got a billion
dollars
the divorces would set it all off and if
you guys are out there in california he
got to keep the parking lot
that's right that's true everybody gets
their 50 if
they're 50 bucks just to go set set tire
on there
to take 13 hours to drive in and out too
oh my gosh
that's a going bomani that's why we have
you on thanks for doing this let's do
this again real soon
really appreciate it sounds good man you
boys have a good one you got it that's
uh bomani jones everybody check out his
podcast the right time with bomani jones
on espn podcast app as well as where all
apps can be acquired the right time with
bomani jones i just love the way he
looks at the world hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here